foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
tetic ESPN NFL analyst senior writer
podcast host TV contributor joining us
on the program Mina good morning how's
morale
well it's great
like I don't think I've ever
been busy you're on a lot of different
shows NFL live Monday through Friday and
then I saw you on around the horn you're
breaking down the games this weekend and
I said to fritzy mina kimes needs to
come on because uh you were giving me
some great insight there so if you want
to recap a little bit but I did want to
start with this the most overrated
storyline this weekend is what
oh the most overrated storyline I don't
know if people are serious about this
but Trevor Lawrence winning on Saturdays
is kind of cracking me up
um a lot a lot of a lot of very uh let's
just say lesser quality schools in that
Saturday record okay and the uh most
underrated storyline
you know for underrated I don't let me
think usually it's like guys returning
from injuries that come to mind for me
um so I'll throw one out there I
actually think you know we talked a lot
on the cap to the Cowboys game a lot
about Dak Prescott uh which gave us I
think more confidence going to the
Snyder's game certainly than we would
have otherwise seen that performance but
I really thought the return of Leighton
vanderesh Cowboys linebacker was
integral for playing San Francisco
because if they didn't have them I think
that defense wouldn't have a chance
you brought up some things about the
Giants now playing the Eagles Eagles off
last week Giants seemed like they got
momentum Danny dimes uh are they going
to turn him loose is he going to run so
give the audience a little bit of a
summation of what you saw the last time
these two teams played
yeah it was week 14 right because the
final game of the season didn't count
and the Eagles as a refresher people who
have forgotten absolutely trounced the
Giants now I was thinking watching that
and thinking okay how are these teams
different what could New York do
differently and then one thing that
jumps out of course is the Giants were
missing uh several players on his
defense he returned and you shall make a
contribution in live in the wild card
game especially in their secondary
Xavier Kenny adori Jackson but the
Eagles also were missing Dallas Goddard
and the Giants are probably the worst or
one of the two worst defenses in the NFL
at defending tight ends you saw that on
display also by the way with TJ
Hawkinson I think for the Giants to have
a shot in this there's a lot of
confidence right now coming off in the
Minnesota game and I do think it is
earned this is a Giants team that is
extraordinarily well coached has
improved a lot over the course of the
season is agnostic when it comes to game
planning offensively they'll completely
tailor their game plan to their
opponents however you could not have
grown up a worse offensive game plan for
them than what Minnesota did now Eagles
fans are a little bit worried because
their defensive coordinator Jonathan
Gannon runs like a similar South Zone
but watching week 14 even when they were
in zone I was just struck by how much
better they are at tackling and closing
than the Vikings are and I think this
Eagles pass defense really might be
underrated I don't know do you guys feel
that way it feels almost like people
forgot about the Eagles I don't know if
it's because versus heard or yeah right
like this is a really dominant football
team I don't think they have names
that's the you know they don't have a
Jalen Ramsey or an Aaron Donald they
they're they're missing that but I think
if and you watch more tape than I uh
have certainly but the offensive and
defensive line it feels like the Eagles
have the best team for having both those
offensive line defensive lines is that
fair assessment how they grayed out
a thousand percent and that's an issue
for the Giants because you know Dana
Jones and saquon were terrific last week
but Dexter Lawrence took over that
football game and then unfortunately
who's there you know nose tackle who
might be the best passer actually knows
tackle in football but the Eagles as you
just said have probably the best
interior offensive line in the NFL and
then the other side nobody really talks
about their pass rush but Hassan Reddick
who was an All-Pro I think that
surprised some people have had a hell of
a year and unfortunately for New York
outside of Andrew Thomas that left
tackle still a lot of weaknesses on that
offensive line what do you see when you
uh watch uh Brock Purdy
um I I I just first of all I'd say I
like I enjoy watching him so much
because he has so much dip on his chip
like he just will try sidearms throws
making plays on the Run uh that I don't
think we've seen like a Niners
quarterback really do it's very funny
when
um you know there's pressure and he he
is able to make stuff happen outside of
the pocket but for the most part you
know watching him against Seattle it's
just watching someone kind of pilot a
well-oiled machine and you're hoping in
the first half he wasn't very good
you're hoping that they can just you
know execute pull all the levers and
execute because I mean I'm not the first
person the Niners offense is so
welcoming up and the skill players are
so impossible to cover you don't really
need that much at quarterback you don't
need someone who's going to elevate
things outside of a few players here and
there we talk about the Cowboys and we
always Center focus on uh the
quarterbacking position and Dak
Prescott's talked about you know certain
things you needed to clean up and Mike
McCarthy talks about certain things that
he needs to clean up what exactly does
he need to clean up
yeah not I actually think McCarthy's
done a really good job this year
um especially navigating some of the
injuries so I when I watch them and
certainly when I watched them on this
last weekend outside of the of course
extra point Fiasco they were pretty
flawless I I you know Dak was this is
his best game of the season maybe the
best game of his career and obviously
the turnover is a thing you're going to
go to first but the thing about last
week that struck me is so a lot of Dax
turnovers happen because he throws us
into Tight Windows so let us go to
Cowboys receivers don't get a lot of
Separation but it's also like Dak
Prescott has never seen a steam ball he
didn't want to rip and watching against
the bucks he was still ripping him like
he was still throwing that ball into
Tight Windows
pop you know in Another Universe some of
those could have been picked if they
were kicked again he had bad luck during
the season but I personally like that he
is stuck to that aggression because when
the receivers actually come through and
when you know the offense is rolling he
is so hard to stop
I we want to come up with a new uh
category it's called RCI receiver caused
interception
because I like that because there are
moments where the wide receiver runs a
different route or he has it in his
hands and it goes through and then it's
on the quarterback because Dak had I
think four receiver caused interceptions
this year
can you uh can you work that into uh NFL
live I love that
I love the interception rate is so
deceiving and uh it was such a bummer to
me too that week 18 he had that horrible
game because I was like oh this is what
people actually who don't watch that
closely think he's been all year you
know what I mean he was awful but for
the most part it'll have those
interceptions really really were not his
fault
um yeah will love this because he always
blamed his receivers for all of his
interceptions
yeah but he he's not like uh the biggest
deck
um no I don't know if he'll love it but
I do like the stat I do like the stats
we're talking to mina kimes NFL live
Monday through Friday on the mothership
at four Eastern
I'm Gonna Make You the GM or the owner
of the Ravens
how do you clean this mess up
well I you know for I actually really
was encouraged by John Harbaugh coming
out and saying that Lamar Jackson was
going to help take the next offensive
coordinator that's if you're a Ravens
fan that's the exact thing you want to
hear
um I I I want to say you know giving
Lamar Jackson anything close to the
DeSean Watson track contract you know
huge deal with a ton of guaranteed money
by the way the reports are he really
wasn't offered that much but it's always
hard to get specifics about that
relative to the other Elite quarterbacks
but I get that you know he has had
injuries but to me you have to do it not
just because of the caliber of play the
MVP season the fact that everyone in the
locker room uh seems to adore him and
you want to reward your best players but
I don't really see what the Ravens would
do if they didn't pay Lamar Jackson
they're not going to get one of the free
agent or trade quarterbacks I believe
um and then if they were to get like a
Godfather draft package from you know
one of the guys picking at the top I
mean how many quarterbacks have we seen
in the first round playing out over the
last few years it just feels like such a
crap shoot when you have a Bird in Hand
to as an elite skill set so I would pay
him I would get it done this off season
and then I would find an offensive
coordinator you can grow the passing
game as well as bringing in a number one
wide receiver but I wonder if the Ravens
can give him the deal the Browns gave to
to Sean Watson because the other owners
were reportedly angry that you you're
giving him 230 million dollars
guaranteed now can the Ravens who
probably you know voice their
displeasure with the Browns do the same
thing with Lamar Jackson
I don't think they have to
courts were that they offered him less
guaranteed money than Josh Allen and to
me you know you guys know being the
highest paid quarterback is like being
the oldest living human being you just
kind of lived longer like it's just
about the passage of time and like I I
feel it felt like okay well if you're
doing the deal after you got to give him
more it doesn't necessarily mean it has
to be fully guaranteed but you have to
offer him something that's commensurate
not only with his value but where the
quarterback Market is moving
directionally
I was wondering if how many great
quarterbacks we have in the NFL I'm
gonna I'm gonna have Brady and Aaron
Rodgers Emeritus but Mahomes is great
Joe Burrows great
Josh Allen's great
right
yes absolutely okay who else is great
uh
uh like well I think you just named the
guys in the top tier I would personally
put Justin Herbert in there not
everybody agrees with that but to me he
is an elite quarterback
um and then you know I think Jalen hurts
his
uh who's pushed himself into that
conversation this season with his play
as passive not just as a runner uh but
you know I would say maybe great
somewhere between great and good what's
a good adjective awesome I guess well
often sounds better than great really
good there's a lot of really good
quarterbacks after that
um high in
honestly I think Trevor Lawrence is in
there like I just think he's played such
good football I'll put Dak Prescott in
there by the way I also think he's
played really really really good
football
um those would probably be in that next
year for me yeah because I I think we
thought we were you know moving on with
Roethlisberger and Brees and we were
going to be in a good spot we're going
to be all these great quarterbacks and
it feels like there's only three of them
I I want to see Jalen hurts in the
playoffs I want to see Dak Prescott in
the playoffs because to me that's where
we measure greatness or we we're ready
to Christen you as great when when we
say playoff results
but honestly one of the best like
statistically if you go into all like
the nerd stats like EPA per play and his
efficiency and
you know it it ranks up there with some
of the best performances we've seen of
the last five years and and people are
kind of poo pooing Tampa as being a
terrible team and they are a bad team
but that offense is not a defense for me
it was not terrible and Todd walls is a
very good defensive coordinator and he
just carved them up I mean I I was so
impressed by that game great to talk to
you Amina thank you we appreciate your
time
bye guys have a great day that's me at
times